ugly scenes at the heart of westminster
as saqiya stama was confronted by a mob
outside parliament and subjected to a
barrage of insults
protesters shouted traitor and accused
the labour leader of protecting
pedophiles by not prosecuting jimmy
savile when he was director of public
prosecutions
[Applause]
boris johnson has faced calls from mps
to apologize for accusing sakir last
week of failing to prosecute savile
this leader of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions mr
speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile as far as i can make out
mrs speaker
that prompted the chancellor ishi sunak
to declare he would not have made the
remark and the resignation of one of the
pm's closest aides policy chief manira
mirza sakir was walking back to
parliament with the shadow foreign
secretary david lammy after they
attended a briefing on ukraine at the
ministry of defence
it's a walk of barely a couple of
hundred yards but that was still enough
for the mob to surround the two
politicians
responding to the intimidation of zakir
the pm tweeted the behaviour directed at
the leader of the opposition tonight is
absolutely disgraceful
all forms of harassment of our elected
representatives are completely
unacceptable
i thank the police for responding
swiftly
but mr johnson stopped short of
apologizing and is now coming under
increasing pressure from senior tories
to limit the damage
i would be saying to the prime minister
go to the house of commons tomorrow
say how very sorry you are about the
manner in which secure was treated
yesterday
and apologize for any part that anything
that you have said when a prime minister
does create damage
it is difficult to see how they can move
forward
my preference would be
for the prime minister to take
responsibility himself for what has
happened
opposition mps are furious in their
condemnation of the prime minister i
think that was a profoundly cynical move
it was an attempt to distract from his
own problems but more importantly i
don't think it shows any concern for the
the victims of jimmy savile whatsoever
and it's a deliberate deliberately
incendiary and in the end it's inciting
the mob stop me you pathetic little thug
the home secretary pretty patel also
condemned the accosting of sakir and mr
lammy and revealed she was in contact
with the police
two people have been arrested
but the labour leader played down the
incident saying he was soon back at his
desk in the commons and was still going
to play five side football
nothing gets between sakir and football
a labor source said
but he'll be grateful the police came
between him and the mob
john craig sky news